hi mystery recapped here today I'm going
to explain a Filipino Irish
psychological horror film called nocebo
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
Christine is a 40 year old mom who has a
very interesting life she is a popular
fashion designer specializing in
children's wear one day while she is at
a fashion show she gets a call from
someone Christine heads inside her
office and as soon as she picks up the
call her expression changes the person
on the other side reveals has several
burnt bodies are being dragged out
devastated by the news Christine hangs
up just then a severely tick infested
dog arrives in front of her it is scary
white eyes with no pupils the weird
thing is that the Fashion Show is being
conducted on the 24th floor so there is
no way an animal could navigate its way
up here scared Christine tries calling
for help but before she can do so the
dog shakes its body and unleashes all
its ticks one of them bites Christine in
the back of her neck the next second the
dog is nowhere to be found it is
mysteriously disappeared Into Thin Air
doggone it that really ticks me off cut
to eight months later Christine is
taking medications for a mysterious
illness she is always tired can't sleep
at night and has Amnesia meaning she
cannot remember things her husband Felix
tries his best to take care of her but
Christine wants to be left alone to
divert her mind she still goes to work
every day she also tries spending as
much time as she can with her daughter
Bobs one day while Christine is alone at
home there is a sudden knock on the door
it is a Filipino woman named Diana who
claims that she was called here to work
as a housemaid Christine thinks for a
while but doesn't remember hiring her
nonetheless since she has become very
sick she decides to make Diana the new
housemaid Christine shows Diana around
the house and arranges a room for her
once she leaves the housemate opens her
suitcase which contains her clothes and
other stuff Diana then brings out a
picture of her child and stares at it
with great intent this makes her
reminisce about the day when her
daughter was born strangely Christine
who is lying down in another room also
has the same vision after a while Diana
notices a chubby tick on the floor and
puts it inside a matchbox she she then
places the matchbox inside her suitcase
and heads downstairs right when Felix
and Bobs also arrive Diana introduces
herself to them but the two appear to be
cold towards her after the little girl
leaves angrily Diana offers to cook
dinner and Christine accepts in the next
scene Diana is seen cleaning the
fireplace she packs a large amount of
Ash in a newspaper for some reason just
then she hears the couple arguing from
the Next Room Felix is angry that a
housemate has been hired without his
approval in reply Christine says that
she will give Diana a week if her work
is not up to the standard she will be
fired in the evening the new housemate
gets to cooking dinner she makes a
delicious meal and adds some shady
looking herbs to it the house bird sees
this and begins chirping loudly she's
putting pot in the food but Diana
silences it with a deathly stare soon
after she serves the food to the family
and hopes for a positive response to her
Delight everyone loves it they commend
the Filipino flavor she has added in the
meat I just used salt and pepper you
racists she says meanwhile as Christine
tries to pick up a glass of wine her
hands start shaking she also has a sharp
pain in her arms Diana who appears to
know a lot about traditional healing
immediately goes over to help She lays
Christine down and starts tickling her
all over the body the procedure looks
very unorthodox but surprisingly it
works Christine can now move her hands
freely without any pain witnessing this
Felix is impressed and he finally starts
accepting Diana as the new house made at
night after the family goes to bed Diana
sneaks inside Christine's Workshop there
she looks at the sewing machine and then
a picture on the wall in which Christine
is posing with a little Filipino girl
this reminds Diana of her own daughter
who for some reason isn't with her now
before going to bed she places the ash
that she had collected earlier on her
doorstep she then hears sounds of a
young girl saying I am with you the next
morning the little girl bobs notices the
ash in front of the housemaid's doorstep
surprisingly there are tiny footprints
on it indicating that his child had been
here last night meanwhile Diana wakes
the couple with breakfast in bed
Christine thanks her for her kindness
but says that they prefer to have
breakfast downstairs in the kitchen
hearing this Diana leaves but not before
taking a good look at every corner of
the room it is clear that she is up to
something before heading to school the
mother and daughter have a private
conversation inside their car bulbs
talks about the strange Footprints she
saw earlier but before she can elaborate
any further Diana interrupts them it
turns out Christine has invited her to
familiarize the route to bulk's school
unfortunately along the way Christine
suffers from severe memory loss making
her unable to recall the way to get out
of the car and try to search for
directions on Google but Christina's
become so ill that she cannot even type
properly Diana sees this and asserts
that she can heal her using a Filipino
folk remedy Christine normally doesn't
believe in superstitious stuff but since
no medicine is able to heal her and
since she can't remember anything anyway
she agrees to give it a try following
this the two return home and Diana
prepares a smoky room she then fills
some dirty water in a Mason's jar and
starts cleansing Christine surprisingly
the remedy works and Christine starts
feeling a lot better she curiously asks
Diana how she knows all of this stuff
and the latter reveals that it was
transferred to her by an Uma hopefully
not the one that killed Bill many years
ago when Diana was a child a strange old
lady came to her house on a cold rainy
night she was an Uma a supernatural
being with the power to heal or destroy
one day the old lady passed away and her
powers were transferred to Diana in the
form of a small bird the little girl
suddenly becomes conscious of the nature
around her and started connecting with
the herbs and plants using them she
could heal people in an instant many
regarded her as an angel but some
believe that she was possessed back in
the present Christine finds the story
hard to believe but Diana explains that
the only thing she needs to believe is
the treatment the following day
Christine brings a list of symptoms that
she experiences on a day-to-day basis it
includes hallucinating loss of hearing
and even daydreaming she also explains
that whenever she visits a doctor the
symptoms immediately vanish Christine
then asks Diana if she can cure her
completely to which the latter replies
sure in the next scene Diana starts the
treatment which includes Ash baths
acupuncture and even some Voodoo
which involves burning Christine's air
unfortunately this only worsens her
condition forcing her to revert back to
her medication one day however Christine
doesn't find her pills she asks Diana
about it but the latter explains that
she herself ordered them to be thrown
away later while Christine is inside her
room she suddenly Hears A child crying
near the sewing machine and she goes to
inspect the entire room starts burning
Christine screams for help and when
Felix finally arrives the room reverts
back to its original state worried about
his wife's condition Felix approaches
Diana in her room and asks her to stop
messing around with Christine however
the housemaid claims that she is just
trying to help she wants to chase away
the demon from Christine's head and cure
her once and for all this enrages Felix
but he decides to deal with her in the
morning as he leaves the room a bird
suddenly attacks him Felix tries to swat
it away but ends up smashing it against
the wall to his horror it is their pet
bird all tits Fox yo royman Felix
is perplexed as to how it got out of the
cage the next morning a distraught Bob
buries the bird and Diana takes this
opportunity to get close to her she
manipulates the little girl into
thinking that her father is a murderer
she also promises to be by her side
forever with this Bob's feels a little
bit better and she finally accepts Diana
as her friend over the course of the
next few days Christina continues with
her Hocus Pocus remedy and starts
feeling a bit better so she heads to
work to pitch her new idea on the other
hand Diana has started picking up and
dropping bulbs from school every day one
day after school she takes the little
girl to a park to have some fun this
reminds her of the time when she and her
daughter used to bond and click pictures
together at home Felix is alone so he
decides to find out more about the
housemaid he looks under the bed and
finds a bag containing all of his wife's
medications when Christine returns home
he immediately informs her about it
shocking her in a fit of rage she
confronts Diana and tells her to get out
of their house right now surprisingly
the weird housemaid doesn't even resist
she goes straight to her room and starts
packing her belongings before leaving
though she releases The Tick inside a
vent she also meets bulbs and asks for
one last favor saying that it is vital
if they are to remain together forever
shortly after Diana finally leaves
making Christine and Felix breathe a
sigh of relief that night the two are
sleeping peacefully when Christine
starts acting up again she sees that a
giant tick is sucking blood from her
husband's face the next morning bulbs
lies to Christine that Felix was the one
who stole the medications at this point
the little girl has become so attached
to Diana that she is willing to set up
an argument between her parents the plan
works and Christine chastises her
husband for lying to her poor Felix
tries to explain that he is telling the
truth but of course Christine does not
believe him that night as Felix is
walking up this stairs another bird
starts attacking him this time he is
unable to swat it away and ends up
falling from the stairs soon paramedics
arrive and take him away now with her
husband gone Christine starts getting
more and more Paranoid by the day she
becomes unable to take care of her
daughter the tick bite at the back of
her neck has also become considerably
larger to distract herself from
everything she attends a kids fashion
show one day but this turns out to be a
big mistake Christine again starts
hallucinating she sees that everyone has
become infested with large ticks
terrified as she starts screaming and
acting like a maniac everyone believes
that she has totally lost it because of
this her manager asks her to stay at
home until she gets better Christine is
devastated that she has been temporarily
fired making her plunge into an even
deeper Abyss at times she doesn't even
recognize her own daughter and scolds
her to go away shoo I would never name
my daughter boobs one day while she is
lying on her bed the doorbell rings
Bob's goes to check and gets excited
when she sees Diana outside even
Christine appears to to be relieved she
begs the Voodoo Woman to cure her in the
latter obligest the procedure begins as
Diana feeds Christine with a spoon of
Ash following this the movie goes into a
flashback One Fine Day Diana takes her
daughter to her workplace a cloth
Warehouse from the tag on the clothes we
get to know that the owner of the place
is none other than Christine herself
coincidentally she arrives at the
warehouse to inspect she talks to the
manager and tells him to speed up the
process by ordering the girls to work
faster she also asks him to lock all the
doors just to make sure that no one
steals anything after a while Christine
comes across Diana's daughter and clicks
a picture with her this is the same
picture that we saw in Christine's room
earlier some days later it gets very hot
inside the warehouse so Diana requests
permission from the manager to go out
and have some drinks unfortunately as
soon as she leaves an AC vent short
circuits and some nearby clothes catch
fire in no time the entire Place starts
burning and since the doors are locked
none of the people are able to make it
outside by the time Diana realizes what
is happening her daughter is already
dead she breaks down in tears and vows
to take revenge against the owner of the
place it is then revealed that she was
the one who teleported The Tick infested
dog into Christine's office earlier back
in the present Christine has become very
Delirious after consuming the ash Diana
forces her to sit on the sewing machine
and do double shifts she then explains
how her innocent daughter had to die
because of someone else's mistake now
Christine will have to suffer the same
fate a few hours later Christine becomes
very ill and starts puking blood then
she is teleported into a room with
flames all around her she even sees a
gruesome image of Diana's half-burnt
daughter Christine screams for help but
soon the fire burns her alive after
eliminating her Target Diana meets bulbs
outside and wishes one final goodbye she
then gets on the roof of the house and
commits the unthinkable once she stops
breathing the bird from inside her mouth
transfers into Bob now she is the new
Uma the movie ends as Felix arrives home
only to find his wife burnt to a crisp
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching